buddy welcome hopefully you are here to
see me my name is Ian Cooper talked
about a venture and collaboration what I
mean by that is when we have an
advantage of an architecture how do we
get different say micro-services in
their architecture to collaborate with
us each other to give basically
functionality I have tended to notice
over time teaching kind of messaging
workshop and working at various
companies that one of the key problems
people run into with an event-driven
architecture is trying to understand how
I get all these different micro services
to collaborate to solve a problem that's
what it's talking about that's just some
information about me it says two things
to you one that I'm old and the other
essentially that I currently don't work
I don't work for any kind of consultancy
I had nothing to sell you apart from
just share my experience the point I
always draw out most of all is the one
at the very bottom of the deck I
encourage you all to get up and speak it
can be intimidating to look at speakers
and imagine that we are all very small
people I hang out in the speaker room
with a lot of them and they like me I no
smarter than you I promise that you are
not they're just the same all of us are
just lucky enough to have been given the
opportunity to speak user groups or
other events and build confidence which
is the main thing which lets us come
stand in front of you guys but I am no
smarter than any of you I promise
so if I can get this stuff so can you
how many dotnet devs in the room any
Python devs okay so I work on an open
source library called brighter brighter
is a c-sharp messaging library it
provides an equivalent to say mass
transit or an service bus always have a
Python / version called bright Sun I
wish interrupts with it and we also
support the functionalities we like
mediator so if you're interested in
getting messaging working and a dotnet
application or a Python application
please do check us out we are hopefully
friendly and always open to people who
want to work
and source project pick you for the
first time so please do come along we've
got some nice new open issues people to
start work on and we try and help her as
much as possible and I get to channel so
we have a get to channel to advertise on
the github page and we'll try and help
if we can
alright enough preamble we're going to
talk about so we'll mention the we're
start talking a little bit about an idea
from a guy called Pat Helens from a
white paper called data on the inside
versus data on the outside we will talk
a little bit about this notion of how
this applies in service-oriented
architectures and micro-services will
then look at requests versus
event-driven
architectures and we'll have a brief try
can't try an understanding of what or
what it was one of the key advantages
that event-driven architecture is
promise you over a question of and
architectures will ask why that can be
hard to obtain unless you know some key
patterns that you're going to want to
apply to preserve those benefits in
pipelines and reference data we'll talk
about those patterns and how you apply
them in correctness we'll show you some
of the things you to understand what
those patterns work work correctly into
name and in compositions and
conversations as a few additional pits
the bits that are helpful to understand
once you have an event-driven
architecture that are not necessary
related to the main thrust of the rest
of the talk all right so let's talk
about later on the outside versus data
on the inside so I'm kind of I guess
unfortunate or lucky enough to have
begun my kind of career towards
architecture when we had
service-oriented architecture as a thing
and Don box who worked at Microsoft on
comm is probably one of the fathers of
SOA and he come up what we call the four
tenets of service-oriented architecture
which are on this deck and we're gonna
talk about in a second now you probably
all think I've got micro services SOA is
yesterday I don't I don't care about SOA
there is a pretty much a direct line
between SOA and micro services
Microsoft's can be just seen as a modern
evolution from things that we have
learned so
the thought works Excel we're architects
now what's from the effigy I cook with
Jim Weber and Jim Weber basically looked
at the state of SOA which so it started
with web services soap you know Dom box
cool so was behind WCF sort of that
model and people have found over time
that led to a requester of an
architecture which we can talk about
later and have problems
give credit SOA to which basically work
with events will show you how you do
that but they've got kind of captured
and they got captured by vendors vendors
lovely people obviously and they decided
that they wanted their slice of them
effectively this architecture they
wanted to make some money from it so
they created the thing called the
enterprise service bus the idea was that
all of your communication should go
through Enterprise Service bus will help
you with workflows will help you with
mapping between different message
formats in different systems BizTalk is
an example really of an enterprise
service bus from Microsoft and the
problem with those es B's was that they
were centralized components quite often
looked after by centralized teams in
your organization where you had to fill
in if you worked in large enterprises
forms in triplicate to get access and
people shoveled a lot of the business
logic into this centralized component
rather than leaving in the micro
services and Jim carpenter the idea that
he called guerrilla micro services a
grill aside rather Agora so I said what
you really want is just to have your
micro services and you want to see
something simple you can deploy yourself
like have HTTP calls between the
services or essentially have a
lightweight broker lat rabbit and when
Martin Fowler and James goes to find
their micro services concept they picked
on some of these ideas when they built
their definition you can find on
Martin's Blakey and that one was
basically repeated as smart endpoints
dumb pipes so they really evolved a lot
of those ideas and brought some ideas
from DevOps and DDD
that we're also emerging the times has
been kind of what is this what is the
current state of understanding micro
service is the term itself comes from a
guy
Oh Fred George fragile is also famous a
program anarchy some of you may like
program Anarchy it says that the
developers should be in charge nobody
else really knows anything it sort of it
should all be about software developers
sort of us just working directly with
the customers we're gonna file all the
product managers they know nothing we're
gonna fire all the QA who needed them
and we're all gonna write tiny hundred
line services those in the body will
replace them every so often so I tend to
think of Fred's version as extreme SOA
it's kind of SOA and I've turned the
dart up to 11th as well attack fans but
um otherwise you can just think of a lot
running assent and the reason that's
useful to us is because much of the
literature about SOA is still relevant
in the world of micro services so a
couple of things to understand here the
first is basically what could we think
of as a typical micro the rules about a
micro service and this is what we get
the four tenets which you can see above
so one of them is the boundaries are
explicit what we mean by that well we
mean that the only way to interact with
our service is through a well defined
API that could be an HTTP API
it could be G RPC it could be events
over AMQP that were not worrying about
the technology choice that were using
but what we're saying is there should be
a well-defined
API which is hopefully stable so we
basically partition our system into
micro services we seek stable boundaries
things that won't change too much over
time and that's why there's often
alignment with the business's goals
business capability sometimes it's
called nothing else can peer inside that
boundary slightly event horizon on a
black hole ok what is inside belongs to
the owners that micro service the team
is building it they can change the code
as much as they want they can change
from using sequel server to DynamoDB if
they want it shouldn't matter to anybody
else how they implement their service is
entirely up to them provided they mayn't
in that contract that contract is a
dependency you can take anything inside
is off-limits they also said that
services are autonomous what you mean by
those I should bear to release my micro
service and have no impact and other
services provided I don't change my
boundary contract the boundary contract
remains the same I can release the whole
thing that means I can't share database
tables why you've aisle 8 my boundaries
and B I'm no longer autonomous because
if you release me how do I know they
haven't breakin somebody else who was
reading from those tables directly so
you can't peer beyond this boundary that
we've established around our micro
service a couple of other ones that are
useful but not so relevant to the talk
we share schema not type in other words
we don't use dotnet Assemblies between
two micro services as a way of
communicating what that's going to be a
parent a wire we use a format like JSON
or XML or protobuf whatever is
appropriate and that allows us actually
to not care how the other micro service
is implemented I don't care how it's
implemented I just care it has a
contract right the other team could be
writing it in Lua for all I care as long
as they provide the contract and if and
they provide a decent SLA and if you
work in larger organisations it's
inevitable that you will eventually
acquire a state of a larger number of
frameworks and languages and
question.why policy is probably the
least significant most of the time that
really says in order for me to make a
call to you were gonna have to agree
certain things like how we do
authorization and we have a policy based
approach to that so we'll agree or we're
going to use it or Thor whatever okay
but one of the things to understand is
that even though I suggest that this is
kind of a black hole or my details live
inside data has to leave my
micro-service otherwise it's not useful
they - leaves via that stable boundary
so you might for example issue a get
request can I have some data from your
micro service please and so we're going
to use a example of hotel booking I know
nothing about hotel booking if you work
in hotel software I apologize from the
bottom of my heart for trashing your
domain but it's useful because you know
I don't let my CV includes nothing in
hotels so you're not talking about
nothing real and they raise events from
my micro service right I read an event
that says this thing interesting thing
happened in my micro service would you
like to know about it
and there are a couple of interesting
properties - those things that we raise
from our boundary so we so we don't own
that data there's a single writer of
that data it is the micro server so that
writes the data inside so we are not we
have no authority over it is just
basically a copy that floats outside
it's immutable there's no point in you
changing that data it won't cause an
update so the dates in the database
contain with inside the micro service it
is stale as soon as the data leaves my
boundary it is possibly incorrect if you
can imagine that someone does a post
into my booking service to create a new
booking when you go and get the list of
bookings if that post comes in seconds
after you've got the list of bookings
your list of bookings is now stale you
don't have the information about that
new booking that just arrived after you
took the get bookings list for one of
those that's one of the reasons with
things like HTTP we will do things like
put for example a cache control header
on the information we will say how long
do I think it's safe for you to hold
onto the
information inside a cache you can keep
a copy but it's gonna get stale it's
also a reason for example we have
something like a last modified or an
e-tag on an HTTP header we say I'm gonna
give you a way to determine whether the
data you hold is still accurate and so I
can make an if modified since um I get
requests and say you know I've got a
copy locally in my cache is it still any
good or do I need to get a new version
and so essentially we version the data
because it is style to determine how
current our data is oops and Pat calls
these two put ideas of data outside data
data that lives outside our service we
authored it you can have a copy of it
you can cache it you can work with it
and do whatever you will with it an
inside data data that essentially
belongs inside our micro service and
obviously that you have a relationship
but from the point of view of people
outside I didn't know what that
relationship is we are inside data maybe
they look very much like our outside
data but it might look entirely
different
park that piece of information in your
mind we will come back to it let's talk
a little bit about requests versus
architectures versus event-driven
architectures and why you might favor an
event-driven architecture so I'm gonna
go light on the detail there are a lot
of a lot of things going on but let me
just like I try and highlight the
particular issue let us imagine that
when I get a direct booking into my
company I decide that essentially what
I'm gonna do is take a credit card
payment inform housekeeping that there
is a booking on a given day and go to my
channel manager so that's covering
things like Expedia bookings comm all
the places where I advertise my hotel
and tell them to decrement the
availability of rooms for that given
date one of the problems if what I'm
doing here is making a call via HTTP
plus Jason or G RPC is that I need all
of those services to be running in order
to complete my booking you can think of
this like a phone call right I know we
don't make phone calls anymore and my
mum phones me but everyone else we just
send text right but back in the day of
phone calls if I phone you up and you're
not there I'm kind of frustrated because
I can't complete whatever action it is
that I wanted to look at and so if the
channel manager is down for example my
problem now is I can't I may not get a
completely booking because I've coupled
my booking to the channel manager
obviously there are some workarounds I
could choose to ignore the fact that
basically I fail to talk to channel
manager and I'll have that situation to
continue there's a particular property
of requester and architectures that you
bind your uptime to the uptime of all
the services you're dependent on if all
of your services have 99.9 uptime and
you have about four of them that gives
you 99.5 uptime at best that's an outage
every day on average in about ten
minutes now you may say 10 minute
but I work for a currently for a food
provider called Justi we connect
consumers of restaurants and delivery
partners and ten minutes during peak
order is a lot of orders hundreds of
thousands of orders that we haven't
taken and delivered to our restaurant
partners so though ten minutes doesn't
seem very much it's at the wrong time of
day it's an enormous Li long window to
file for so the question is can we try
and avoid these problems or a question
of an architecture now just as an aside
if you are forced into this model that's
what you get into low balancing across
various instances using our service mash
acceptor to try and give you a reach
rise in the circuit breakers so there
are solutions but one solution is
basically to move to an event-driven
architecture so with an event-driven
architecture I simply raise an event
that says I have a direct booking and I
have all the other micro services simply
subscribed to a channel which is
identified by a topic or a routing key
that says I want to hear about new
direct bookings
thank you very much that'd be really
great and so for yourself a housekeeping
just says I'm gonna listen to direct
bookings and we send in a message and
the thing is this is a synchronous and
decoupled it's like because we don't
send phone calls anymore I send you an
SMS right I sent you an SMS and you can
you can retrieve it in five minutes when
you finally get to look at your phone
when you finish that important
conversation that you were having about
what you learned at NDC Osler today and
that asynchronous property means it
doesn't really matter to me if that
other service is not available at that
time what it will do you just stick them
in a queue we refer to this as
guaranteed delivery
okay channel manager will eventually get
that message now there is an issue
called eventual consistency and that
means if channel manager is offline then
comes back online again there is a
window during which our
availability will look greater than it
is out there to basically customers
using our service on booking.com or
Expedia ok and that is potentially a
problem but businesses solved that
problem for many years before we has
software and so the usual model is a
hotel will simply direct that booking to
an overflow hotel where essentially it
could be dealt with but I said - you've
got time as well you could contact the
customer and say I'm sorry we have to be
fully booked on that date and I'm afraid
I'm going to have to cancel your booking
ok and here's some is a voucher for your
next booking or ever more award points
or some mechanism that usually the
business will understand to solve that
problem ok
as an interesting aside I had a
situation where I arrived at a hotel
where from eventual consistency reasons
my house housekeeping had not rented the
ring in time was a very expensive hotel
and they simply said to me sir go to the
bar and greet as much expensive alcohol
as you like and will tell you when your
room is ready and I was quite glad my
room wasn't ready for quite some time
and I was quite drunk at that point
right so there's always usually adequate
business solution to the problem or
eventual consistency ok but that's a
question that usually comes up at this
point so I go away I'll be very excited
I'm gonna build event-driven
architectures Ian's tell people about
them I've got my copy of n service bass
or brighter or whatever off I go and I
building my system and I say great we
can take a direct booking and direct
booking for a customer and account and
the customer with the account his credit
card heaters aren't part of the booking
we go and look them up again it's the
credit card that we've got stored on
file for the customer how are we gonna
look up his account details because if
my answer is that I request that
information from the accounts micro
service I've just reintroduced temporal
coupling into my workflow now in
principle in this kind of scenario I
could retry a few times
maybe because accounts has got my
message essentially I think to myself
it's fine I'll just keep retrying but
any flow are effectively you want to
complete within a reasonable time window
this could be a significant problem
right
if accounts is down how do I finish this
operation in a way that essentially is
going to allow me to release the
resources I'm currently using in the
credit card payment system which are
trying to get a hold of information out
of accounts so we're going to do is try
and solve that problem in the event
different way rather than resorting back
to using requests so there are a couple
of options really so if we look in the
lower left hand corner of that slide
what we could always do is ensure that
the message that is received by the
credit card payment service has all of
the data it needs to process the request
so I simply make sure that from
somewhere I've obtained your credit card
details and added them into the request
such that you can process it correctly
all right and we're gonna explain in a
second what your options are for filling
that data in on that message assuming
that it's not in the direct booking so
the classified a direct booking not an
account and they've got according their
credit card I may have it right from the
beginning the process but assuming in
this slightly contrived scenario that I
have to get the information out of the
egg from the from your account details
how do i how do i add that to the
message given that the direct booking
event was raised by the direct bookings
micro service not by the accounts micro
service and the second option which
we'll get to after that is that my
payment service has the information it
needs in a cache it is cached
information from the account service
about accounts and their credit card
details that it needs to service its
requests ok and the clue to the what
we're going to do is to think back to
that early sex
about reference data right remember we
can cache data coming out of a service
so messaging tends to work by pipes and
filters model I have a source of a
message I have some endpoint destination
which I want to get you to service the
request but like in a certain arbitrary
number of steps between the two and I
simply published a one channel pick up
the request and then I essentially
consume from another channel and it's
important usually so a channel you mean
think something like a topic or a
routine key depending on your technology
of choice it's important understand that
you have multiple channels involved so
my direct bookings publish is something
like direct booking made on account and
the account service listens for those
messages and it says are as a direct
booking made on account I need to enrich
that message with the credit card
information when I've added the credit
card information I will raise a message
which is I mean that direct booking made
with credit card details and the credit
card system listens to that message and
says great I've got a direct booking and
I've got the credit card details I can
take the payment so while using that
pipeline we are able to leave micro
services as the single authorities about
their own data I don't have to let you
call me to get hold of that data VAR a
request or even worse reaching beyond my
boundaries of my database I simply ask
you to complete a pipeline where you
will enrich the data before it reaches
me now you can't have a little bit of
concern about a latency I'm making some
extra hops maybe if I need something
high-performing this is not the better
option you come back to our options a
second sometimes that model gets quite
complicated so the previous way of doing
it were essentially
a pipeline I passed events between one
and the other we tend to refer to as
choreography all right I am simply
letting events flow around the system
and I listen to this event you published
that event etc okay another model is
called orchestration and orchestration
says a component an Orchestrator usually
thought of logically as being at the API
gateway layer couldn´t conducts the flow
of operations so it says I want to make
a direct booking and the direct booking
system says okay great I've raised a
direct booking in the direct booking
system and that sagar then says okay
great i need to fill in the account
details because basically the type of
booking was a booking on account
hey account system fill in the account
details on this message and it passed it
to the credit card system and says hey
credit card system here is a message
basically of our direct booking for this
account go and take the payment and a
trivial example like this there's
probably no significant advantage over
the first flow but the real advantage of
this process is I can add compensation
so compensation is what I do when
something goes wrong right what do I do
when your credit card is declined
now you can actually in this particular
case so the problem by choreography if
you want to as well so I just had a
situation where my credit card had
passed over its expiry date for a
booking I've made in a hotel probably
nine months ago and actually all that
happened was they just phoned me up and
they said mr. Cooper could you give us a
new credit card
that's called manual compensation right
effectively and that's quite possible
choreography we have a booking status
and something that goes to the bookings
every so often and says all other any
bookings that basically have a status of
effectively you know card declined or
well but with this process of a Sardar I
can manage that in some way right the
Sarkar can effectively update my direct
booking and say
change display status - but card
declined it may send an email to an
operator saying please contact mr.
Cooper and tell him his car
is been declined and he needs to replace
it with a new one etc and I can control
that flow and it also gives me a central
point - usually because storing state in
some kind of database generally a song a
state machine and it's sorting database
saying so I can go and query that and
say where is mr. Cooper's booking and
that's useful if someone gets on the
phone to a call center and say I thought
I've cuz I've just complain saying you
know I made a bookie your hotel in the
15th and I've received no confirmation
someone can go in look at the state of
that particular transaction and it says
to them mr. Cooper's card was declined
and they can then say to me your card
was declined mr. Cooper would you like
to present a new card right so having
some kind of saga helps manage that
process okay but earlier on we talked
about this model right we said the
patterns are defined that there was
outside data and inside data and the
outside data was what comes out of a
micro service in the form of data we get
get for a basically an HTTP request or a
G RPC request or events that we raise
from the boundary of the system and that
data is a mutable style and versioned
and it is very suitable for caching so
what I could do is listen to events
being raised by the accounts system and
the account system would publish events
when a new account was created or it was
updated and maybe it raises quite
specific events like a credit card
details updated so I only had to listen
for a fraction of the events coming out
of the account system ones that I know
I'm interested in well it lets me do is
build a cache of the account systems
data that I as the payment service own
and can access it lives within my
boundary it's my copy
I've only use a small number of fields
that the account system actually creates
when it publishes for example the credit
card number the CBC code may be your
some of your address details so I can
confirm those
but I can listen to the account system
and construct a cache which I can then
use at runtime to service my requests so
account says something like you know
credit card details updated a worker
process running inside my micro service
updates my local cache of account data
and I just sit there listening to events
and recounts updating my own version of
what lives in the account system and
then when a booking event is raised I
can simply ask my local cache about your
credit card details rather making a
request back to you and the significant
advantage of this model is that I am
essentially now insulated from your
system and it's it's uptime and
availability because I can service
requests without accounts being
available a cat you can't add a new
account and you can't update your credit
card details accounts is down but from
the flow of me with taking new hotel
bookings that's viable and seeing that's
probably my money-making flow that's
what I want to protect against the loss
of availability of a service
so while accounts I may not care for
couches down for a window time the
lights up a window saying so are it's
not possible to add in your account at
this point in time certainly with my
booking flow I want to make sure there's
no real impediment and if you're booking
on account right telling you to come
back later is probably gonna cost you
it's gonna go somewhere else but with a
model like this I'm insulated from your
system I don't I have no dependencies
right I read I received the event and
I'm able to act on it on my own and in
turn credit card payments after it's
essentially made the payment will raise
its own events and that can be listened
to by systems downstream from credit
card payments which may in turn be using
the data for their own purposes for
example may be raising financial
information accounts invoices reports
right I don't care who they are they can
have a cache of my data as well they
don't own that data right it's
potentially stale they should they
should track version numbers against it
but that data essentially is usable by
them to process requests
the process of using events to create
reference data can show you that again
is called event carriage state transfer
Martin Fowler named it recently we've
been doing it for years
but mine's now named it so that's great
we can all talk about it it exists now
another thing in technology exists and
Kyle Martin names it I'm not really sure
but yeah you met earlier on people quote
often referred to it by just the term
reference data and one of the
interesting things I noted over time
about reference data is that for example
it's in if you're in the breast in
practice they refer to reference data
but don't explain it they just assume
that you understand what it is it's like
going up one of the great secrets of
architecture and building event-driven
architectures the single reference data
people say oh and if you're building
reference data you should do this and
people are like what is reference data
right so you may see the term reference
data eventually the term projections
because people often liken this to a
CQRS model where effectively I have
commands coming in to a system and I'm
generating a view off that basically
from what happens there and you might
people relate it as well too many ideas
an event sourcing where effectively you
are building a projection of a stream of
events
so there are rated ideas if you really
want to cause a fight on Twitter because
you're bored one afternoon you simply
say something like on Twitter hey I'm
really interested in using Kafka for
event sourcing as what caused a fight
really most of the scenarios that the
CAF group like confident describing for
Kafka are actually event carried State
transfer not event sourcing but upsets
people it's finally got the popcorn
understand back and watch basically as
the blood congeals on the floor okay so
um if we tape it around for a while so
veterinary State transfer is one
approach to doing it but there are
others atom feeds so you may see this
one talked about a von Vernon who's here
somewhere at this conference I think in
one of his the major design books talks
about this model so at one point people
would say I'm going to use an atom feed
to expose all of
the events that have happened inside my
micro-service and they use an item fee
because it has some interesting
properties and one of those is that
every page after the current page is
immutable it won't always have the same
contents and that makes it very easy for
you to read an event history because I
start on the current page and I just
keep paging until I see the first event
that I recognized then I go back to the
beginning and they use a lot of etags to
tell you whether you put the pages
change so I can query the current page
and say are the new entries on this page
so I can poll that and only read in that
case so it's a quite efficient mechanism
nowadays because there are better
technology choices available it's used
less than it was in the past but it's a
very easy to access version if you have
trouble installing middleware etc in
your organization extract transform and
load so people have done this a lot in
the past was simply replicating data out
of a database in one like SOA into
another SOA right lots of banks in
London for years have done I've used
this approach of replicating their data
everywhere by using ETL so valid
strategy the problem of course is ETL is
not always the best particularly for
doing things like you know sending using
transaction logs but other systems but
also you're binding yourself to using
the same database technology usually
across all your micro services that may
not be what you want to do you know one
micro search might want to use a graph
DB one might want to use basically
dynamo or cosmos and so that kind of
binding you're you're removed of that
from that dependency on technology by
using essentially events as the medium
of actually to transmit over you can use
FTP as well write as a no perfect buy
strategy the more modern equivalent will
be write something to blob storage
somewhere effectively and read from that
instead and essentially you're doing
pretty much what some of the message
globe provides which took about a second
D by creating effectively an append-only
stream of photo of events so very
strategies you can use I do a lot of e
CST but then I'm kind of an events guy
but you can pick other ones if you want
to okay there are various types of
reference data you can share an operand
data
our friend data is essentially useful
when you want something like a product
description right or some of those tiny
oh I've got an ID I want to have the
description so I can return the
description in my you make a get request
to me I've just got an idea about a
product in another system rather than
effectively having to mix get recalls to
both systems so I can just fill in the
description I can have it in my
reference data and I can just include
that in the return value shared
collections so share collections or
mostly what this is used for and so we
say things for these are lists of things
that nearly every micro service in your
system needs so list of customers or
users of the system lists of companies
basically registered to use your
platform so just eat for example I use
that list of restaurants list serve
customers list of delivery partners ok
because most of your microservices will
need that data in somewhere to operate
and it saves you continually making
request based calls to those other
architectures I just think about this
way if you if you slightly Jebus if I
was gonna remain AC to be your request
to get that data then that desi fee
request would surely indicates to me
that I could cash it because AC feat
that's how the web scale as we cache
data and you cached locally you cash by
secretly at the point of the consumer
not the point of not in the origin
server so what I'm doing is caching the
HTTP request data but if I do the event
carriage state trance from just doing
off an event and I read that local cache
rather than asking you again for the
same data and historical artifacts it's
not I got the facts coalesces for your
transactional system that tends to be
more I am filling my data Lake full of
stuff based on the events that had on
the microservices because it turns out
and now I put all my doctor in these
individual micro services it's very
difficult to create queries across
multiple micro service boundaries so I'm
going to take all that event data and
I'm going to shove it into a massive
Lake where effectively I can then query
it my my biggest tip is that reference
data should not know the rules what I
mean by that when I receive an event or
make a get request to you I ain't
print the data you give me myself by my
own rules what I don't do is copy your
rules from inside your micro service and
then apply them to my service because
then I've coupled the main knowledge
between these two micro services and if
it changes in one it's gonna have to
change in the other okay
so you need to better interpret that
yourself don't replicate the rules and
if the data in the other micro service
has to be understood by complex
algorithms for example we have some
stuff adjusting about you know delivery
radiuses etc on where we'll deliver to
and what time windows are about that
it's not a suitable artifact for
reference data you're better off using
that kind of pipeline approach in doing
choreographer orchestration to fill the
data in that context you're going to get
more latency because the great thing
about reference data is it's pretty low
latency just calling the database rates
faster than making that request of an
architecture was in the first place and
it's certainly faster than basically
filling that pipeline of the better
messages it flows through a choreography
or orchestration so don't pick reference
they too were essentially you need to
bring the rules with you most of it
should be fairly basic stuff but for
some credit card details you know the
account system has no rules about it
it's the credit card payment system
that's going to have the rules about it
correctness okay this is the hop up so
I'm gonna just drink some water my
battery's low
all right so if I am sending data from
say my accounts system and it's been
picked up by the credit card like
receptors downstream I want to make sure
that they both agree on what the current
state of the account is what the credit
card information that you put on file is
there's no good me trying to take a
payment from a CRO historical credit
card and then saying it's declined and
you finding up the customer and the
customer saying but I gave you in the
you credit card details yesterday you
might get a really latency of a small of
a short window the customer is probably
gonna tolerate that but yesterday's
enemy no good so you to make sure that
the changes in the account system always
flow to the downstream credit card
payment system okay so in this
particular in vivexx there's also this
particular model right the the service
essentially that effectively wants to
change its own state to the auto service
it's going to like to the orders table
ignore the outlets for the moment and
it's also going to write to the message
broker to send a message downstream to
say hey I have changed the state
basically of this given record so we'll
just use the example of the council sets
account service and today after message
broker it's unlikely that we can create
a transaction across our message broker
and our database probably the two
technologies don't share any kind of
distributed transaction coordinator
maybe if we're using MSM queue and were
using sequel server that will work but
essentially even then we'd use a scaling
issue that by basically holding a
transaction open across two resources
everything will slow down that creates a
risk there's a risk for example that I
might write through my database and
update it and say here in the new credit
card details when I try and sent to the
message broker I fail it's down for
whatever reason
okay and then theory there's also a risk
which kind of says I could I could swap
that around I could say well I solved
that problem
I'll Center my message broker and only
if I succeed this thing in my message
break while I update the table that
creates the reverse problem I may now
have told the downstream account system
the credit card has changed we're not
the upstream account system and that may
cause problems in the future for me so
I'd to fix that problem as a pan called
the out box and the out box says what I
do is they create a table and I write in
a transaction to the accounts table that
has my credit card information and the
outbox table and I put the message I
want to send into the outbox table and
typically if I'm using relational data
store I have some header properties that
say things here like here the head of
purpose of the message and a feel it's
just some JSON or whatever it has the
body of the message stored inside it and
then I send the message knowing that I
safely got that message in the outbox
and I have two strategies practice you
one which is kind of my preference says
I put it in the outbox and I just send
the message as normal strategy to says I
send the message directly from the I
read the outbox table and send a message
from the outbox
okay I prefer the first strategy because
otherwise I'm tended to use the outbox
table as a cue which means I have to do
some interesting sequel to get that to
work right now if I fail to send to the
broker what I can do is have another
process that my worker process running
in the background that says okay when
did you write to the outbox table have I
seen that come is that a timestamp
saying it was sent via the message
broker so when the broker sends it
updates the outbox table and a messaging
it says with a timestamp I've sent the
message at this time point okay if I
don't see one of those I know that I
should
send it so this worker force is spinning
in the background says are there any
messages older than five minutes that
don't have a timestamp I'm gonna resend
those now there's a risk and the risk is
that when I relate to the message broker
and try and update the outbox table I
fail because the database is not
available right that's okay I just send
the message downstream anyway the
downstream system has to basically deal
with duplicates that's what we tend to
refer to guaranteed at least once
delivery because I may send you the
message more than once okay so I send
the message downstream so I can
guarantee that you will eventually
receive any of the updates made to the
outbox table and there can be an issue
here and the issue is that essentially
some databases for example MongoDB I'm
not going to support a transaction
across and an accounts document and an
outbox document so what can I do
okay look so the other option we can use
called a log tailing if your database
supports it and log tailing says I am
gonna listen to the transaction log on
the database and use that to generate my
events so dynamodb for example an AWS
supports this against listen to its log
as the log generates events I say okay
that transaction log is effectively what
I'm going to use for my outbox and I
will effectively listen for those events
and I will raise events to send them on
the broker downstream and dynamodb
replication itself is actually done by
effectively listening to the transaction
log pushing events over Kinesis and then
reading them on the other DynamoDB
instance and updating the table effect
on the other DynamoDB instance the
dynamodb does this as its method of
replicating between two systems if
neither of those work my third option is
I write to the broker and when I've
succeed
that right into the broker I listen to
the message that I've just written to
the broker and update my own state so in
this equation both sides listen to the
broker to update state but the data
source and the data sink okay as
obviously it slight downside with this
and that is that essentially timing
issues can mean to the downstream system
knows about something before the
upstream system does and you get things
like the customer get notification that
credit card has been debited for a
certain amount and you haven't even
confirmed their order to them but you
see these things catch up right and
customers are often tolerant to that
kind of problem but it is a little bit
of a funky one because people are
sometimes a bit like I don't write my
old local state I just listen to the key
okay logs versus cues you can also have
this discussion we could call it rabbit
and Q versus Kafka if you like right so
things like RabbitMQ have a model we
call a shared cube what do you mean by
shared Q I mean that when I send you a
message downstream when you pull it off
and update your accounts reference data
we delete the message off the queue so
it's gone okay I keep eating messages
off the queue I can tell where I am
because the head of the queue is the
next thing to process but what happens
if I introduce a new service into my
environment particularly happens in
non-production warrants for like QA some
races a new version of their service I
used to build my cash my cash is empty I
don't have any credit card data how am I
going to fill it so the archer in this
model is that hopefully I have an outbox
and I resend the messages out of the
outbox saying here's all the things that
happened in accounts and the problem
with this model though is that everybody
now gets a notification of all the
things that happen in accounts and they
have to have some kind of hopefully an
inbox for the deduplicate where they say
discard it I've seen it discard it I've
seen it this guy that I've seen it right
and I've got other work through Frank
for well the system is basically in your
parts your system just two on board this
one you Microsoft's and publishers cash
or because you want to blow the cash
away for whatever reason to start again
okay so the avanti's the message log
systems like calf girl Kinesis and i'm i
think it streams in as you I'm not Nazir
person and have is that I don't delete
what I do is I've advanced the index
pointer but the data remains essentially
because it's written to disk and I can
reset the index pointer back to zero or
a new service can start at zero and
consume all the events it's a bit like
that atom feed we were talking about
earlier okay
new service points towards the accounts
feed I read nothing so far I'm at zero I
guess go reading all the way through
service has been around for ages maybe
record forty thousand or whatever right
generally speaking to do this though you
have to rely on the ability to store
that data forever or at least do some
kind of snapshots to let you truncate
the donor at some point so that you can
start from a given origin Cass Cass I
think good infra tension which really
helps with this you can look at other
models for example like saving snapshots
out to s3 as a starting point for your
data generally my experience has been
that message log star technologies are
easier once you get this working to
deliver event card select transfer and
indeed you talk to people like confluent
they see the event care estate transfer
model as being one of the key successful
scenarios where you can deploy message
globe arts based technologies over share
cue technologists right reversed
trade-offs between the two technology
choices but this is definitely one of
their sweet spots where they work very
well and it's this stuff that tends to
cause the oven with the event sourcing
people
and our box and inbox don't tend to be
near such the message logs because the
message lock itself is the art box in
the inbox eventually and there are even
technologies for a job or for example
called streams which although I never
tried it in theory we suspect may be
usable to build actual reference data by
pointing at the stream of data without
having to do it directly but I've
nothing I already played with okay so a
couple of things to touch on just at the
end which kind of relate to this piece
and I just try and give you the full
picture so this is mostly been talking
about what happens in event-driven
systems when I want to in micro service
when I want to basically handle the
workflow from some kind of request
coming in to to do some work or tasks
cuz reach me right what happens in
Microsoft's what I want to get data so
typically you essentially have a model
of composition either by the client or
we're gonna show next guide the server
right so the client simply says there
are as an accounts micro service credit
card payments direct booking service I
just talk to all of them and if I need
data I'll just get the data from all of
them they're outside the perimeter it's
very difficult for them to talk to any
kind of event model so you have to rely
basically on good old request driven
architectures so you can get that the
client or effectively you can do it the
server when you form part of the gateway
the main reason for doing that the
server is some reduce to latency right
rather than making that call effectively
from your mobile phone twit to get
across to twelve api's to get the
service I just basically make one call
to your software effectively and it
makes the cause internally toast 12
services basically and then you can also
do lots of management there because
you're a question of an operation around
retries circuit breakers all that stuff
to say history is pioneer that now we
get in service meshes the other model
though that's what kind of more
interesting for this discussion is that
I can build what's sometimes called a
composite view model and that says if
what I want to do is take data from a
number
our services and build something it's
just a simple kind of select statement
it just says give me a row give me four
or five rows of pre calculated
information then I can actually just
listen to events and build a read-only
projection from basically that reference
data that you can then query this is
affecting this idea of historical
artifacts it's particularly useful if
you can avoid cooling a micro-service to
calculate something you can just say I
can calculate ahead of time what then
what this result will look like so when
the user queries it's just simply a low
latency cool into a database to get
their data back and that saves you from
this world having to cool multiple API
to decomposition if simply querying a
pre-built
cache that looks like the results of
their query alright so this basically
art look lovely a bit of animation and
we're building up our of you and
typically these things out water
histories I that's where the the
customer wants to see something that
ranged across a range of data in theory
although it's really kind of outside the
scope for the topic of this talk you're
doing exactly the same thing we bought
data like right the data Lake is simply
really just listening to all the events
that happen in your verus microservices
collecting the data and putting it
together in some big store that you can
then go later and effectively great
queries against alright one more to go I
was getting excessive there okay and
with that we are done there's a couple
of minutes for questions I suspect if
anyone wants to ask a question I can see
you can always come and grab me i'm i q4
on twitter and where DMS are open so you
can just direct message me and i'm happy
to talk about this stuff
ad nauseam so but otherwise we are done
and please don't forget to vote for me
green tickets are our votes
[Applause]